- La pandémie n'a pas ralenti
leurs arde
et 2021, le Canada a accueilli
un nombre record d'immigrant
Ils sont 1,3 million,
en majorité originaires
et de la Chine, à avoir choisi
le Canada.
d'accueil la plus prisée.
44 % des nouveaux arrivants
ont décidé de s'y étab
entre 2016 et 2021,
une augmentation d%.%.%.
À l'inverse, le Québec,
qui arrive deuxi
le choix de 15 % d'entre eux,
une baisse d%.
Et une nouvelle tendance
se dessi
en moins nombreux à choisir
les grands centres.mumumumumumué
nord-afric.......
- Caroline Arcand est directrice
de Prescott-Russell, dans l'est
ontarien. Elle observe cette
tendance qui fai
des entreprises de la région
c c comme ailleurs, manquent
de travailleurs.
emploi, Prescott-Russell, Ont.
- Ça m'encoe e e énormément
de voir que les immigrants,
oui, choisissent des milieux
de Prescott-Russell,
peut-être une cinquantaine,
soixantaine d'individus,
rapproche de plus près d'Ottawa.
- Et le plus g d d défi,
selon elle, ce n'est pas
de séduire les immigrants.frfrft
le processus d'immigration.
- Le ministre de l'Immigration
reconnaît qu'il y a du travail
"Il faut faire plus
dit le ministre,
sans préciser cot.t.t.
Même scénario au Québec,
la seule province qui actctctctr
les travailleurs qualifiés
désirant y immigrer.
Le premier ministre Legault est
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Donc, on va le regarder
d'une façon nouvelle avec des
sugg
Puis, il y a une nouvelle
ministre, Christine Fréchette,
qui est ouverte aux suggestions.
Mais, ce que j'ai dit,
il faut arrêter le déclin
du français au Qc.c.c.
- 70 % des nouveaux arrivants
n'ont ni le françaismemememememe
maternelle. Quand vient
le temps de choisir l'une
des deux langues officielles,
qu'à l'extérieur du Québec,
9 grgrgrants sur 10 ne parlent
qu'anglais, alors qu'au Québec,
plus de la moitié d'ent uniquem.
Ici Valérie Gamache,
Radio-Canada, Hawkesbur